welcome back to the toast I'm so excited
for today's guest first of all Jay
Shetty is here which is like such a big
deal biggest podcaster maybe like you
know you and the toast two of the
biggest podcasters ever Guru author
podcaster Jay Shetty thank you so much
for being here Claudia I'm so grateful
to be with you and I'm I'm really
excited because like I said my entire
team is full of toasters and they're
such huge fans and it's an honor to be
with you I'm really excited I would like
to thank all the toasters who made this
happen thank you all for your hard work
Jay you are like such a big deal I don't
know if you know and honestly I feel
like the magnitude of your work didn't
even really hit me until I got to L.A
and I was just telling my friends and
different people I'm like oh I'm
interviewing Jay Shetty we've had cool
people on the podcast like you have a
profound impact on people like I I can't
really describe how different people's
reaction to you coming on the show was
than from anyone we've ever had wow I
mean that makes me feel so grateful
honestly and I feel humbled by then so
thank you everyone who's been listening
to purpose and supporting and the
podcast well so I'm curious like I feel
like you're always interviewing people
and you're now in my hot seat like are
you nervous I I enjoy this especially
when even the first few moments we spent
together because I love learning more
about myself yeah and learning more
about someone else in this process so I
I I wouldn't say I I yeah I feel nervous
a little bit yeah I know I mean my
favorite thing on the planet is to talk
about myself so I love giving
interviewed but I know it's not for
everyone you know I feel nervous when I
care that's what I've realized of course
I feel nervous when I care if I don't
care then I won't feel nervous anything
worth caring about is like gonna give
you like absolutely yeah yeah and yeah
so I feel like you have this huge
podcast and I I think we have really
different audiences and and for anyone
who might not be familiar with your work
your background is so interesting
um you're a former Monk and I have so
many questions about monk life you know
like did you have a cell phone no no
right like truly cut off no cell phone
yeah and I know because I've done a lot
of research on you but can you tell
everyone how you got to that place
living in India being a monk yeah so
just to give context so I left it's
pretty incredible to think about this I
left around 10 years ago now oh wow so I
left the monastery 10 years ago it feels
like another lifetime at this point uh
but I got there because when I was 18 I
was fascinated by learning about
people's lives I would love to hear from
CEOs and celebrities and athletes and
I'd be going to events this is before
podcasting I'm amazing myself but you'd
have to go to a real life event you'd
have to get a ticket you'd sit in the
seats and you'd listen to someone speak
but the best thing was what you can't do
after a podcast is you could wait in a
line to say hello to the person yes and
so I would do that every time whoever
spoke because I'd love to connect with
them one to one and one of the times I
was invited to hear a monk speak and in
my head I was thinking why would I want
to hear a monk speak I was like I'm too
cool for that like what am I gonna learn
from a monk so I told my friends I said
I'd only go if we went to a bar
afterwards that was literally my request
and my friends persuaded me and said
yeah sure sure we'll go to a bar
afterwards so I come to this event I'm
thinking it's going to be a waste of
time I'm looking at my watch I'm like
come on let's go to the bar
and it was amazing because I went there
and I found something I wasn't looking
for I wasn't lost I wasn't necessarily
searching
but the monk was talking about how the
greatest thing in life was using your
skills in the service of others and I'd
never heard that I always heard it was
to use your skills to get girls making
money or yeah get famous and he was like
no it's to use your skills to help other
people and help other people heal and
help other people feel happy and I was
thinking as at 18 I'd never heard that
before and so I said to him I want to do
what you do and so for the next few
summer and Christmas vacations I spent
them studying in the monastery and then
when I graduated I decided to trade my
suits and my internships and my
corporate career ahead of me to go and
live as a monster what were you planning
on doing before I thought I would either
be an investment banker or a strategy
consultant or something in that world
wow that's what I was training to do I
mean I was giving up my passion and
desire for art and philosophy which was
always my heart but and so you spent
three years in India yes and you were
fully in it fully in it when I say fully
I mean I was I mean there's so many
pictures of this but like head shaved
right wearing robes uh you live out of a
gym locker like everything you own fits
inside no material items literally no
material ideas you have access to like
communal uh computers to like email your
family and like keep in touch with them
so what did your family think of this so
my family was kind of being prepared as
I was doing these trips but my extended
family was so worried they were like
you've been brainwashed right they were
like you're never gonna get married no
one's ever gonna talk to you again I
remember my friend and we were each
other's wingman and he was like who's
gonna be my wing man now like what's
happened to you right he was like well
now I can't talk to you about girls that
I'm dating and this and that so it was
like you know now it's really
interesting because a lot of people are
like well Jay it sounds like this story
is like something people are really
connecting with you but I was like
becoming a monk wasn't cool it wasn't
interesting it was like the weirdest
thing I could have done and it was so
far from trendy right when I was doing
it and I had to face the reality when I
came back because 40 places rejected me
before an interview I applied to 40
companies online and I wouldn't even get
an interview because surprise surprise
you were a monk for three years they're
like what are your transferable skills
so you put Monk on your resume it's oh
yeah it said monk at the time yeah yeah
yeah that's so interesting yeah I feel
like you would bring a level of like
peace and level-headedness to the
corporate environment I think it would
actually be good but that's that's
that's that's you saying that that makes
me feel better but trust me when I was
interviewing everyone was like what's
your transferable skills sitting silent
right and we don't need that what are
you going to bring to this company and
so when you decided to leave how does it
work when you you leave it's because
like you feel like your time is done or
you were over it like or is it once a
month always a monk are you still
considered a monk no so I'm married now
and oh Mercier amongst gonna be married
uh I always have businesses monks don't
have businesses and so I'm not not a
monk at all anymore and that's why I
always say former monk uh but leaving
was really interesting it's self monk
training is like self-awareness training
in the extreme form because you spend so
much time alone yeah and the irony is
after spending so much time alone I
realized I wasn't a monk I realized that
wasn't my path I realized that I had a
rebellious streak in me I wanted to do
things my way I'm I'm independent I'm
strategic I wanted to use all of that
and monk life is sacred it's it's not
for that so I feel that I took the best
learnings and teachings from that time
and now I still apply them I still
meditate in the same way as I used to I
still follow so many of the same habits
and practices but now as I wrote my
first book I choose to think like a monk
not live like right and my goal as well
how do I take all of that into my mind
and my presence without having to live
that externally so you made this
decision to like take what you've
learned which most people don't have
access to that kind of Zen or that
philosophy and help people and pay it
forward and that's what the podcast does
and that's I'm sure you do speaking
engagements what is the actual Journey
like from leaving a job or a monk dumb
with nothing and then actively starting
your own business like literally like
you did you have any money no so there
is so much in that I I love that you
asked that question the transition
that's a great question because everyone
always thinks it happen overnight and it
kind of sounds like that sometimes but
it doesn't so I went I moved back to
London I moved back into my parents home
because I didn't have any money moved
back into the bedroom I grew up in I was
25 000 in debt because of my student
loan and lucky student loans in the UK
are not as bad as in the US so it was
only 25k comparatively that's not
terrible at first it's not terrible for
the us but it was it was still pretty
bad for me over there and the first
thing I did was I felt depressed and I
felt lost and I felt confused because I
thought wait a minute I thought I was
going to be a monk for the rest of my
life I'm not now and now all the doubts
that my family had started to be true so
I had uncles and aunts telling my mum
and dad we told you so yeah who's going
to give him a job now well who's gonna
marry him now like you know all that
kind of stuff started to come back and
all my friends were now established
people had been working yeah they were
buying a car and they were renting a
home that's tough comparing yourself to
like other people's timelines exactly
and you're coming back to everyone kind
of having progressed and you haven't in
the material sense right and it was at
that point where I realized something
really beautiful that it was at that
point I either had to practice what I
learned as a monk or trade it right and
I realized that being a monk I'd learned
my skills I'd learned how to manage
stress I'd learned how to master my mind
and I was like this is the time to
actually put this all to the test so
anyway going to leading to starting
something from that I realized first of
all I just had to pay bills uh I started
dating my wife when I didn't have a job
or my now wife and I didn't have a job
at the time and so I would tutor I would
literally tutor uh students in like
economics at University or subjects I
was good at just to get paid like 20
pound an hour to get the money to pay
for dates with my wife like that's
that's that's literally how it works I
would like save up just to take it like
into Express or something like that
which is a pizza place in England sounds
good yeah it's it's yeah it's like a
Pizza Hut kind of vibe yeah and and I
would just save up to see whatever I
could do but what I realized was I had
to get a real job so I ended up applying
to consulting firms again again I got
rejected from 40 companies finally got a
job Accenture right Accenture and I
thought least I can pay the bills from
here that's a good job yeah it was it
was a decent job A friend of mine has
worked there he's Rich it was so so I'll
be my starting salary was 31 000 pounds
at 26 years old oh so just just to put
that in the kitchen yeah I was 26 years
old making 31 000 pounds a year yeah uh
and that was my first job and I was just
happy I was just like yes at least I can
take care of my bills stability
stability I'm safe but what I started to
realize which was really interesting is
Accenture encouraged me to talk about my
passions at work and I would talk about
meditation and mindfulness so I started
traveling the whole company teaching
meditation and mindfulness and I was
working with Executives and I was
working with our directors and I was
doing mental health days at work and
they would trust me to lead these days
and I was thinking this is unbelievable
like there is so much need for what I
studied as a monk and two years later
was when I decided to quit that job and
I said I'm about to try and see what I
can do with this I didn't know if it
would ever become real I thought you
know but even if this just lets me do my
hobby on the weekends it'll be great
yeah and so in 2016 I launched my first
video uh on YouTube and the reason I did
that this is a this is a fun story I
have to tell you this so I'd been
chasing Executives pitching my idea for
the content I wanted to make and they
were like Jay no one wants this kind of
mindfulness content right then I was
applying to companies for like trainee
video journalist positions and they were
like well Jay you don't have any
qualification you don't have a
Communications background you don't have
any media background you're not media
trained so I ended up at an ethnic
minority TV Training Day One in England
there were only six brown and black
people in this room right and I went
there to see if I even had the skills
because I was starting to doubt myself
and I thought well maybe I just maybe
this is not happening in this lifetime
yeah so I end up at this uh TV training
day they do a whole day of training and
at the end of it they say to me Jay
you've got some really strong skills and
I was like great give me a job like pay
me anything I'll take it and they said
well there's no jobs in Media right now
and I was like wait great you told six
brown and black people to come here to
tell us there's no jobs in media like
that's great uh and they said well you
should start a YouTube channel right and
the voice in my head said that works for
Justin Bieber yeah because like that
works for one in a billion people right
it doesn't work for anyone else and I
had this really important realization
there's a beautiful quote by Thomas
Edison where he said
when you feel you've exhausted all
options remember this you haven't and
that is something that I've used over
and over again in my life that when I
thought I'd run out of Alternatives and
options I realized I hadn't I hadn't
tried everything and so even till this
day when I feel I've tried everything I
know I haven't even started no that's a
great quote Yeah
okay so you you launch your career your
viral years later you have this podcast
and you've really become like a
a favorite of people in Hollywood and so
much in what I read about your book and
which I loved when you were talking
about how you're so happy you met your
wife when you had nothing because it
really helped you focus on you as your
biggest value not your success is your
biggest value
um and Hollywood is is not the best
place for that and I'm curious what sort
of like monk philosophies are just
things you use to keep yourself grounded
you're very normal honestly I was I was
hella nervous to meet you like you have
this kind of Larger than Life presence
online but you're so normal like I feel
very comfortable talking to you thank
you how do you maintain that in a town
like this so clearly first of all I'm
really happy you read the book like
everything and everything you're saying
I'm like wow you're like really digested
the book we like to read here I know
it's amazing no no but I I know that but
I really appreciate just I can tell that
you've really digested it too it's not
just reading so that's amazing a lot of
it really resonated with me thank you uh
so
how do you do that the first thing I
have to say is that it's a daily
constant practice it's not something
that you can just say oh I already
mastered it in my monk life and now I
don't need to worry it's a daily
practice to remain grounded uh my
favorite tips for remaining grounded for
myself are
I think it's so important to not forget
who you are and where you came from my
best friends are still my best friends
from back in London I was just back
there and I was just telling you a few
seconds ago I was back in London for the
for Christmas and New Year's and I was
hanging out with my friends all the time
friends that I've known for like 20
years and all they do is rip apart my
red carpet looks uh my change in hair
like whatever it is like that was just
but it's the best right because it's
like these are the people I grew up with
they know me the best they care about me
they love me deeply and when you let
them lay into you in that British banter
way it keeps the sense of groundedness
in reality to where you came from so so
connected to where you came from the
second thing I'd say is that
I think you you have to really study
people's lives and I think this is
something I've always done and as a
reader you do and and even as an
interviewer you do when you study
someone's life you actually get to learn
from it rather than get carried away
with how you feel in the moment so what
I mean by that is if you study the Arc
of any successful person in Hollywood
you see a sign of success
uh maybe a rebellion right then you'll
see depression you'll see mental health
you you see all of this and you can
ignore it and think oh that would never
happen to me right and you think you're
the exceptionist I'm happy with all that
I would be happy with all of that and I
think that that's the mindset that sets
us up for failure where we go oh no no
I'm special yeah like I'm better and
it's like well you're not you're human
all of us are human and so I think when
you study someone else's life you
actually develop empathy for them and
compassion for yourself yeah and you
think wait a minute let me be aware of
the natural pitfalls yeah it's kind of
like saying if if one of your friends
has been to a country and they had a
rough experience you've got to learn
from them experience you don't just go
oh no that's not gonna happen to me I'll
be fine yeah I'll be fine
[Music]
hey guys today's episode of the toast is
supported by State Farm the State Farm
personal price plan helps you create a
plan that gives you options so you get
an affordable price and it comes with a
lot of benefits like the coverage you
want a policy that helps cover what's
important to you and an affordable price
just for you here at the toast we are
all about personalization I mean comedy
is more personal than food but what is
more personal than insurance and getting
a bundle that works just for you I know
that Claude personalizes everything from
her very specific food choices to her
expertly curated Taylor Swift playlist
We Are All About That personalization
because personalization means you have
the power to choose what you want to
include and leave out and what you don't
it just feels better that way and why
shouldn't insurance work like that too
that's what the State Farm personal
price plan is all about you can choose
to include options like bundling your
home and auto policies which means
you'll get the coverage you want at an
affordable price just for you in the end
you'll have a policy that gives you what
you want doesn't that feel better yes
y-e-s yes like a good neighbor State
Farm is there can't say it without
singing it call or go to statefarm.com
today to create your State Farm personal
price plan prices vary by state option
selected by customer availability and
eligibility may vary I'm just going to
say at one time this is the first ad I
don't have to write my own jingle for
like a good neighbor State Farm is there
Bing okay and today's episode is also
brought to you by let's get deep let's
get deep is a spicy new game that is
going to spice up your Valentine's Day
so for support for today's episode comes
from the perfect Valentine's Day gift
let's get deep let's get deep is
literally the hottest game for couples
that you've probably already seen all
over Tick Tock and Instagram from the
creators of what do you meme let's get
deep is so easy and fun to play Let's
get into it it's pretty simple you take
turns asking each other fun deep sexy
questions from three decks of cards with
three levels of intimacy you have the
Icebreaker questions the Deep questions
and the deeper questions so you can get
ready to take things to the next level
some of the questions are you know
pretty PG what's your go-to snack at the
movies for me if anyone's asking it is
popcorn with raisinets yeah I know
really crazy another question could be
how do you show your love another
question could be what when were you the
happiest ever so they get pretty deep
and it's a great game to play on
Valentine's Day or just with a partner
when you want to spice things up and
you're in luck because we have an
exclusive offer for our listeners for a
limited time get 20 off with the code
toast when you go to whatdoyoumeem.com
let's get deep that's what do you mean
m-e-m-e.com slash let's get deep and use
code toast again to get 20 off go to
whatdoyoumeme.com let's get deep and use
code toast so let's get deep literally
and the third thing I'd say is that you
know the most important quality that was
drilled into us as monks and I think
about this as culture like you walk into
the offices today there's a beautiful
vibrant atmosphere I met you you were
super warm and vibrant you gave me a big
hug right like we're living a value
every day you are I would love to know
what your values are what would you say
like when you when you greeted me today
like what was in your heart and mind
because I felt it but I want to hear in
your words you know that's a good
question I felt like
what I do and our work is very Niche you
know like if you if you know us you love
us and if you've never heard of us
you're like what is this so I had a
feeling like maybe you know people in
your life had told you about the toast
but you weren't entirely familiar so I
just wanted to be like we're cool we're
fun we're normal like and I also wanted
to Express gratitude because like you
being on the show for us is a really big
get for us you know so I wanted to be
like I want him to have a good time I
want him to think I'm cool a funny nice
smart like I wouldn't leave here with
the biggest smile on his face that was
really my intention it's working it's
working and so as a monk that was
humility the the quality of the the
thing that we were focused on most was
humility like that was seen as the
number one gift someone could give you
and what I found in the most successful
accomplished or anyone that I've ever
met the quality I find most
admirable and endearing is humility and
I've found that one of the the most
successful people I know in the world
are extremely humble I agree and and so
to me because from monk life that was
such a priority quality it's a quality
I'm always trying to Aspire for I don't
think I am humble I think I'm always
aspiring for it because your ego is
always working in there totally but I
think remaining grounded through my
meditation practices through my life
practices and by the way being married
is a great way to be humbled so I was
just about to say like if you're married
yeah exactly my wife will roast me all
day long the team sees it all the time
yeah and it's the best way to remember
I remember Robert Downey Jr I saw an
interview with him once and he was
saying that when he comes home it's not
like his wife and kids are like oh my
God you're just like they're like can
you take the the the trash out like you
know and that's the beauty of living a
real life right so I think and the
beauty of family I think for me one of
my core values is family yeah and I find
like so much of the decisions that I
make are influenced by my family and
just like what my family would think of
me because I know like I hold their
opinions of me in such high regard yes
you know exactly so I want to talk about
your book this is your second book yes
your first book was tell me more I
didn't read your first book I'm sorry no
the first book was much more of like an
intro to you and your philosophy and
then I thought it was really interesting
that for your second book you wanted to
write about love yes why so my Facebook
School think like a monk it breaks down
the practices of meditation mindfulness
uh personal habits habit training
mindset and it does a bit of a piece of
my my experience so that's think like a
monk uh I literally just found out this
week we just in the last two years it's
hit two and a half million copies which
I feel holy [__]
I don't but you don't I'm very offended
so many copies I feel so grateful and I
haven't said that yeah so I'm very
grateful that I I get to share that here
it was unbelievable to see the love that
that book received especially because
and and the reason I'm sharing is not as
like a an ego or a boost thing the
reason why I'm sharing it is 14 out of
16 Publishers when I was pitching the
book told me to change the name they
told me no one wants to think like a
monk they said the name I loved it yeah
they said no one cares and I went with
it because it was my truth and this is
just a reminder for everyone out there
who's being told that your idea is
terrible and you should leave it stick
to your truth wow the reason why I
switched to love for this book is
because I think I've been fascinated by
love my whole life I've dated since I
was 14. I've wanted to figure
relationships out I have failed so many
times in love and today when I coach a
lot of people a lot of the things I'm
coaching them on is love yeah and what I
started to notice Claudia I'm sure you
fill this with your friends I had
friends who were chasing their passion
but they felt incomplete because of
their love life yes I had friends who
had amazing growth in their business but
when they didn't have their partner in
that relationship or I had friends who
were lost and confused but love in their
life was giving them a foundation no
it's so true room and and I just felt
that love was that area that was ignored
in school ignored in college you were
expected to know how to love without
ever having studied it or learned it and
I honestly when I write a book the
question I ask myself is do I want to
get obsessed about this topic for two
years right for six hours a day right
because that's the amount of time that
goes into writing the book so I just
spent the last two years obsessed with
science on love research on love stories
of love and I just felt that if I didn't
write about love I'd be doing the world
of this service because
it's just a unthought about area and
you're just expected to know how to be
in love so when you were writing it
ideally who did you want to pick it up
is it for people who have found love
because honestly a lot of the book
really resonated with me and I wasn't
sure that it would because like one like
I have a husband who I love dearly like
I have found love I have real love in my
life and I was like well I don't need
the rules of love because I got it bye
suckers
um but I found especially chapter six so
much of it resonated with me but who was
the ideal reader in your mind so the
ideal reader honestly was probably
everyone who's listening from the sense
of anyone who wants to find it yes keep
it or Let It Go and I wrote the book
with that in mind because I realized
that I couldn't just talk about dating
without talking about being in a
relationship and I couldn't talk about
breakups without talking about being
single because it's all interconnected
and when someone dives into this book
they'll see how it's genuinely a map
from preparing for love to perfecting
love Yeah and we go through every phase
because this I I I see love is like
levels yeah and it's almost like if you
don't learn what you need to learn at
level one you keep getting pushed back
there yeah and so the book goes through
four levels where it teaches you uh what
to think about in each area and so
whether you're in a relationship whether
you just broke up whether your friend
just had the worst heartbreak whether
you're single and you've been alone for
a while this book has been written with
you in mind yeah and so for me the part
that I keep mentioning is chapter six is
for so I'm married I've been with my
husband for 10 years and our our love
language is bickering we we argue we
argue like any couple but most of the
time like our fights are
nonsense like we're just bickering for
the sake of talking that's just how we
communicate
um and I never was like ashamed of it
and I was never I just I honestly
thought it was funny
um until you know our podcast started
blowing up and he would podcast with me
sometimes and so much of the feedback
was like oh my God so much like and it
would make me like really insecure in my
relationship when forever I've been so
secure in my marriage I'm not secure in
a lot of things but like I'm really
scared of my marriage and reading and
I'm gonna read a quote if that's okay
with you please conflict has a bad
reputation it makes us look bad to
ourselves and to other people we want to
think that we can be the couple who
understands each other deeply and never
fights we're special we're different but
no matter how compatible a couple is to
live in conflict-free Bliss isn't love
it's avoidance every couple fights or
should and I kind of tell you how like
this chip on my shoulder just like kind
of like oh because it I've always felt
that way but I think a lot of people
um
you're right especially in the age of
social media this perception you want to
put forward is like we're perfect oh my
God we love each other we never fight
like we're literally made for each other
and that's just not real and so I
appreciated the amount of realist like
your book was very realistic and very
applicable in that sense but I do think
there are cases where like you actually
are fighting with your partner for like
too much and how do you decipher when
you think or advice you would give to
someone who's thinking like I feel like
this isn't normal yeah yeah absolutely
and I I think there's
you know just just like you and your
husband my wife and I was telling you we
banter a lot right so when people are
around us and they'll see us take real
shots at each other or Digs at each
other they'll be like are you guys okay
like have you got relationship issues
and I'll be like no that's our way of
showing love like banter is our love
it's also cultural you're British and
Jewish yes very like rooted in our
culture exactly and like the more I can
lay into you the more in love we are
like it's a very weird right it's a very
weird concept but but that's how me and
my wife function and and my wife wins
every time by the way she's really good
at mentoring I believe but the point I'm
trying to put forward in the book is yes
there is a toxic kind of fighting which
is abusive emotionally uh financially
financially like any type of abuse or
toxicity is not what I'm saying is the
right type of fighting or arguing but
what I'm saying is that two humans
coming together will naturally have
disagreements disappointments
discussions and debates yeah and when we
want to avoid those and like you said if
we live in the world of
oh you know and we all have a friend who
says to us oh we never argue
everything's all peaceful yeah and I
wonder what are you struggling to say
yeah what are you uncomfortable raising
and actually if you want to live with
someone for a long time you've got to
get really comfortable with
uncomfortable conversations my wife and
I have been together for 10 years we
still have uncomfortable conversations
today so what I wanted to do in this
chapter and if I'm jumping ahead you can
slow me down what I really wanted to do
was help people understand how they
fight and what I realized is that just
as we have Love Languages we have fight
languages or fight Styles so imagine
you're a wrestler and I'm MMA if I don't
know you're a wrestler and you don't
know I'm MMA when we fight it's just
going to be the most awkward
uncomfortable and it's not a fair fight
and it's not a fair fight right and so
what I realized is this chapter was
dedicated to giving people an awareness
that how their partner fights isn't
necessarily a sign of their partner
loving them or not so let me give a real
life example there's three fight styles
that I break down in the book you have
venters haiders and exploders which one
were you do you know I'm like a unique
combination of all three just depending
on my mood I'm definitely more of a
Venter in the sense where it's like what
I'm arguing about it's usually not about
that it's about something else that's
going on and like I'm just pissed and it
has nothing to do with Ben or what I'm
mad at him about put your socks away but
it's it's something else yes that's I
think I'm mature enough to understand
like usually what I'm fighting about is
not what I'm actually angry about yeah
I'm a vented too so me and you're the
same person basically pretty much and my
wife's a Haida right she wants to go
into her cage she wants to reflect about
is that what your husband is too 100
like and it's so frustrating because I'm
like get in here let's just finish this
and he's like no you know what and you
know it's smart because I'm very
hot-headed and maybe if I did take a
second to just calm down I would be able
to express my feelings better but I'm
also I'm productive I'm like I'm in a
business I'm like we're fighting let's
finish this now I don't have time for
this and he's very um more sensitive and
more honestly level-headed so he'll go
to the couch I won't see him for like 30
minutes and then he'll come back and be
like you know what either this isn't
even an argument worth having like I'm
over it or now I'm able to communicate
my feelings in a better it's actually
something like that annoys me about him
but I also really respect yeah I love
that that's beautiful and then you have
the Exploder who needs to just feel
emotionally heard and they want to go
into that space so let's take us we're
the same and our partners are the same
in the early years of my relationship
with my wife I really believe she didn't
care when we fought because every time
we had a fight I would want to talk
about it right now and she would want
space yeah and I would think if you want
distance in space that means you are not
as committed as I am you don't care
about this as much as I do right and
when I broke down the fight Styles and I
realized I'm a veteran she's a Hider it
made me realize that actually her love
is processing like your husband's is
like they need time to process and
reflect so they don't say something they
don't mean they don't say something mean
they don't say something hurtful they
want to think about it and so now that
we know that and my wife also
understands that I'm a solver I'm a
fixer I want to do it right now solution
oriented solution oriented we now
realize okay you need two days I need it
now we're gonna meet in 12 hours right
like we'll find that middle ground of
what's healthy and so I really hope
people use this as a tool as a skill as
opposed to just carrying on having
heated arguments
[Music]
today's episode is also brought to you
by our favorite favorite Society we
heard you agree with us in our DMS after
last week's Spritz Society ad read dry
January is over and rightfully so
because this year we're saying yes to
life and yes to Spritz Society Spritz
Society sparkling cocktails are not only
better tasting but better for you
they're made with real wine low sugar
and six percent ABV Spritz Society takes
all natural recognizable ingredients and
packs them into convenient sparkling
canned cocktails that you can take
anywhere did we mention it's gluten-free
perfect for our anti-gluten girlys if
you haven't already heard I mean you
should have heard that sprit Society was
named the best can cocktail by USA Today
if that isn't a reason to choose these
sparkling cocktails then we don't know
what is so due to popular demand we've
asked for our dry January code to be
extended so you can make sure you get
all your fave flavors at 20 off use code
dry January for 20 off the site for the
next 24 hours that's 20 off all five
flavors and subscriptions at
spritzociety.com
s-p-r-i-t-z-s-o-c-i-e-t-y.com let's end
dry January with the Spritz please and
thank you
even the concept of you breaking down
how people fight like what type of
fighter you are provides like um I don't
know provides like peace in a sense like
knowing that like I'm not a crazy one of
my I was telling you before like my
biggest fear is like becoming like a
[__] wife like I don't always want to
be nagging but it's like pick up your
socks like it's like I struggle between
like how I want to be perceived and how
I'm naturally feeling yeah I mean I
think even just the the way you broke
down what type of Freddy you are I think
can provide Solace for a lot of people
knowing like this is a common
relationship thing because it feels good
to know like other people go through the
same thing totally totally and I just
think it's also good to humanize the way
we respond to conflict yeah that we need
to humanize and normalize that if
someone expose explodes emotionally
someone wants to vent someone wants to
hide these are really normal things yeah
and we don't start judging our partners
or feeling guilty to how we now like I
said toxic emotional abuse like yeah
we're not talking about that like if
you're having those kind of of arguments
that's a different story that's how you
know it's it's gone too far yeah but if
you're also not comfortable to raise
things like I I have this really
uncomfortable thing and I hope it's the
right place to share and you go for it I
do something uncomfortable with my wife
probably every couple of months where
I'll say
is this relationship going in the
direction you want
and if it's not
are we willing to change and if it is
what are we doing right and I love
asking that question and I don't ask
that question because I think
something's wrong I'm asking that
question to make sure we stay on the
right path that's so funny but if I
couldn't ask that question without her
feeling if she felt insecure every time
I asked that question that would make it
really tough so that's so funny I like
literally once a month when we're like
going to sleep I'm like I'm like are you
happy like I'm so paranoid that like I'm
I you know I'm very um I'm self-involved
like I really am
um and I'm always thinking of like
what's going on in my life and and I
worry sometimes that like I like I never
want Ben to feel like forgotten almost
and I'm always like paranoid that I'm
being a good wife and that he's happy so
I'm always like are you happy like
you're feeling good right is there
anything like you would tell me and like
I feel like he doesn't want to tell me
stuff I'm like tell me like part of it
is paranoia but also I think part of it
is just like a genuine response for me
like really wanting like I love Ben with
my whole heart I want him to be happy
and I like live in fear that he's not
yeah you know we discover his men you're
the same person no totally when you say
that I was like oh my God I'm literally
embarrassed like I did that too but it's
good it's healthy to be honest it's
actually healthy because when you check
in regularly with your partner everyone
gets to a space to be honest yeah that's
true and if you didn't check in you
could literally if you don't check in
that's when years from now someone turns
around to you and says this is not
working out and you are like what do you
mean it's not working out you never said
it anything yeah and so I would rather
people check in regularly and hear the
truth in small doses because hearing the
truth in a huge dose is really paining
and so listen to the truth in small
doses it can change your life I also
want him to like feel comfortable like
you tell me anything I'm your wife I
love you like I would never I would
never judge you and he's so good like I
don't think he knows like he doesn't
even try he's just like such a good
person like he's so non-judgmental he's
like never made me feel embarrassed
about anything he's loved me like you
know when I had a you know business was
going great business was what we had
when I was high up on the scale low on
the scale he's never made me feel less
than and I want that so badly for him
and like I try so hard and for him it
just comes so naturally does he listen
to the show no yeah
I'm like I do a podcast every day so
like okay you can't listen to every
single one but I'm like every now and
then right yeah
um so also what I thought was
interesting is like love is an abstract
topic so to write a whole book on like
this thing that you don't
see you just feel
um I felt like would have been a really
hard task but I found you like breaking
down love and almost like an analytical
way
and I thought this was a really good way
to like Focus uh how you said to focus
on
whether you like someone's personality
whether you respect their values and
whether you would like to help them
achieve their goals and I thought your
wording on that was interesting because
you said respect their values not share
their values
um and I I want to believe that there's
a world in which you can have a happy
life with someone who you have different
values from
but you respect their values but I feel
like that's really hard yeah especially
in like this this time in this country I
feel like people are so divided we're
kind of conditioned to hate the people
we disagree with yeah
um but I thought your choice of wording
there was intentional yeah very
intentional and again you're digesting
this book Left Right said I'm so
impressed uh you've you've really like
embodied the essence of what I'm trying
to say which is which is so beautiful as
an author to yeah to receive that from
someone who's reading it so thank you
thank you so much for doing pleasure uh
but but it's exactly that like so I do
like to analyze and make things
systematic and give people principles
and rules and boundaries because I think
when you leave something abstract it can
get really messy yeah right like I think
what happens when you leave something
completely abstract is you think you're
feeling it but then 10 months from now
you realize you were not feeling that at
all when it all blows up in your face
right and I'm trying to help protect
people I don't want people to waste time
with the wrong person I don't want you
to spend two years three years ten years
with someone and feel unfulfilled no so
I'm just trying to set you up so if
anyone goes Jay you're being too
systematic loves more feely loves more
than this I'm just trying to help I just
don't want you to it's like that in the
movies but in real life like you're
building a life with someone you're
having children with someone you're
going financially partnering with
someone it's it is analytical it is
analytical yeah and I and I I hope that
that's what comes across and of course
by the way I'm a romantic too of course
I'm like one of the most yeah I love
romance like I love all of that too so
it the book's trying to infuse both yeah
but going back to your question the
reason why I chose those three things is
because I realized that that so these
three elements are the difference
between a relationship being a
short-term relationship or a long-term
relationship
understanding the person's personality
respecting their values and being
committed to help them towards their
goals now the reason why I said
respecting their values I think it would
be wonderful to live in a world where
you find someone who has the exact same
values but when you really know your
values they're as unique as your
fingerprint yeah that's how unique
values are because I'll give an example
like yes my wife and I are both
spiritual yes my wife and I both value
kindness and compassion but if you
looked at our deepest value and priority
my wife says family and mine is my
purpose I will constantly trade 99 of
things in order to pursue my purpose and
my wife will trade 99 of things to be
with her family right now my wife is
actually in hospital with her grandma in
London uh she's not back in LA because
her grandma's going through something
and that's a priority for her she will
choose that above everything and of
course if she needed me there I'd be
with her too of course
um but my point being that our values
can be very similar and shared but
there's still like a trump value it's
actually so true like it's so personal
yeah do you think that's why I mean for
me at least like when I was dating and
wanting to get married I was searching
within my own Community I grew up
Orthodox Jewish I knew I wanted to marry
someone Orthodox Jewish one because
that's like an important part of who I
am you know furthering the Jewish people
but also it does save you a lot of steps
like in knowing like you know you grew
up similar to me we're probably going to
align on most things yeah I think it's
like a it's a it's kind of an easy way
when you're going to look for someone
and sometimes people hated the way they
were grazed and they reject that and
they go in the total opposite direction
and find happiness there but I think
when it comes to like values it's so
it's so like a core of make it makes you
who you are so it's kind of easy just to
look you know look at the local shul
yeah exactly and like you're saying like
there may be some things that actually
assume values yeah but you may find even
in that community that people are very
different so true and and I think
sometimes you're like oh yeah of course
I know where they went to school I know
what they're into so true and that sets
you up for so much failure like they did
the study this this study is amazing
they did a study where Partners had to
watch video footage of each other and
guess what the other person was angry
about based on their emotions oh they
found that couples who'd been together
for longer guessed wrong more often
because we assume we know the other
person that's true and so that
Assumption of like oh I know where they
went to school I know who their friends
are I know what they're like that's a
good reference but I think doing your
own due diligence and your own Discovery
is probably healthier yeah so the reason
why I encourage the respecting of values
is also because values change as people
grow older and the skill is do I respect
this person for who they are yeah or do
I want them to be who I want them to be
yeah and most people don't respect
people's values because they think their
values are better and so if I think oh
no my value of helping the world is
better than XYZ then I'm expecting you
to trade your value for me yeah or vice
versa and I found that when I respect my
wife's values not only does it make her
happier and healthier it actually heals
our relationship yeah and so yes I would
love to live in a world where we had the
exact same values of course I just don't
know if it's I don't know if that's
possible people are like it's hard to
find someone you know generally it's
hard to find someone with the same value
yeah even when they're the same they're
different which is your point and that's
so true I noticed you don't wear a
wedding ring I don't I never have that's
so interesting yeah I never have I'll
tell you why my wife never bought me one
oh now you blame it yeah yeah that's
that's the reality is let's let's start
the banter so so so my wife never bought
me one she's my wife's a very
spontaneous individual who doesn't do
things on time and and my wife lost hers
in the first month of us being engaged
she was at a supermarket she was uh
swinging her keys around on her
engagement ring and it must have fallen
off and she thought I ensured it I
thought her dad insured it no one
insured it and so now she she just has
my initials tattooed on her which I want
to do too so yeah yeah yeah well
speaking of your wife my final question
for you on the book and then I'm gonna
put you in the hot seat
um I don't know why I was surprised that
you shared so much about your personal
marriage I mean obviously if you're
going to write a book like I don't know
I just I perceive you as this like
extremely private person do you have to
get your wife's permission for stuff
like that like that's a great question
do you have to so I think the stories
that I've told the stories I've told her
yeah or stories that she like would
agree with my perspective on and so yes
I would check in with her and say hey do
you agree that this is the perspective
of how this went uh I'm sure if she told
the story she'd tell it with a lot more
color perspective is everything yeah
exactly because it's not the same right
no you could say the same story from two
different angles and that's your truth
my truth and the truth exactly and so I
I do always check in with her before I
share a story because I I want to see
what she has to say about it so yeah
absolutely but she likes anything from
the book no no no no no no she's she's
she's like very no no I don't think she
did I I did but she hasn't read it so
she doesn't know yet it's fine my
husband didn't read my book until like
the day came out four years to remember
we've had 15 copies in the house for two
months Road
um now this is a pop culture show yes we
are like kind of obsessed with
celebrities and you've had the distinct
privilege of interviewing a lot of
celebrities being invited to a lot of
fabulous events so I'm just gonna be in
the Hotsy for a second and you have to
answer some questions I like doing this
with you because this this is what you
do inside yeah I feel very comfortable
who is it you've had amazing people on
your podcast Kendall Jenner Khloe
Kardashian Kevin Hart Alicia Key Selena
Gomez everyone who's a guest that came
on your podcast and surprised you the
most in a positive way
surprised me the most in a positive
maybe you had some preconceived notions
about this person yeah it means it has
to be someone had preconceived notions
about so one thing I'll definitely say
is that I'm very fortunate that a lot of
the guests that come on the podcast are
people that I know before they come on
the podcast so I don't always have
preconceived notions because I may have
already interacted them but let's think
who surprised us positively
yeah I'll say that in a nicer so I'd I'd
connected with Kendall at a mutual
friend's birthday party she was super
sweet at the party we'd we'd gotten
along uh and then I'd message her and
said hey I'd love to interview on the
show and she responded back immediately
like full of enthusiasm and I think what
was really beautiful for me to see was
just like
how much she was excited by it yeah and
this is the part that really got me and
and I sent it to
um the team the morning of like she
messaged me the morning of saying I'm so
excited to share energy today yeah on
the morning of the show and that it's
not because I had I didn't have any
negative preconceived notions of her
because we'd met but I was blown away by
that because it was so conscious after
the podcast had a text saying oh my God
I love doing that like it was just so
present yeah and even with my whole team
on the day like whether we were like
signing our guest book or like taking
pictures she was like laughing with the
team and connecting with them and so
present I was thinking you know she she
never you know she didn't check the
camera once she didn't edit any pictures
like she was just so comfortable the
whole time and that's so nice yeah I
want people to know that about her
because I I consider it to be you know a
wonderful human and and I feel like that
was one of your most impactful
interviews like I think so many people
have preconceived notions and I'm I'm a
Kardashian fan till the day I die I will
defend them in the death to the comment
section but there are you know they're
probably the most famous family and I
think there's the most kind of you know
fallacies out there about them and
people just think that they know them
and I fee I remember the reaction to the
interview with her being so positive
seeing Clips ever at people being like
wow I totally misjudged Kendall I feel
like that's the best thing that can
happen when someone comes on your
podcast like really showing people who a
famous person is because we don't know
nobody knows yeah and and she was
definitely like she's as true as she
came across that day if not more that's
nice to hear yeah so you also recently
famously officiated Ben and Jen's
wedding which was very private we didn't
get to see any pictures from the inside
so I need you to tell us in one word
what did it look like on the inside uh
it was uh I could tell you more than one
word one one yeah one word might be hard
it was absolutely what was really
beautiful about the wedding is it was
actually very intimate and private even
in who was attending it was it was close
family very close friends it wasn't you
know what people expect of a celebrity
wedding where it's like yeah everyone's
it was just very
beautiful and just intimate and personal
and like warm and like it was just
it was it was love right and that
there's something really special about
experiencing something that way I
remember like and this is something I I
want this is a good place to address it
whenever I read news articles about
events that I'm at or people that I know
deeply in this space it had a whole list
of the guest list of who came I promise
you 90 of the list wasn't there a
hundred percent and that's the kind of
stuff where I'm always a bit like well
who's reporting this right because that
person wasn't there that never happened
that's not the truth and it and it's
uncomfortable because I'm like you know
it's it's real people's lives it's
frustrating you want to just all of us
are yeah all of all of us but it was it
was truly special very intimate very
real very uh yeah really beautiful kind
of like a beautiful full circle Love
Story yeah but when you think back
because I remember when I was growing up
it was like Ben and Jen Ben and Jen and
then like he lived and it was like it
was kind of like a fairy tale for I
think a lot of women like looked at that
and was like wow yeah and and just about
how much growth there and a beautiful
reminder that there was so much
individual growth that had to reconnect
again at the right time I'm so true and
to have 20 years apart to realize that
that was the right thing to do because I
think so often when we break up with
someone on things end we think that's
the worst thing it's it's everything is
worst everything's gone and realizing
that actually that may be the best
Evolution and whether you end up with
someone or not that may be an amazing
part so what a what a beautiful lesson
for all of us and yeah yeah it was it
was an it was an honor to do it and uh
yeah a little little did I know I'd be
doing that so that was iconic we were
honestly we were really happy because
any podcaster succeeding is a win for
our podcast I agree I love that yeah I
feel that way too you have famously been
on Ellen yes what was Ellen like so I
have to so I've been on Ellen four times
wow uh in the last four years so ever
since we met and I remember a year
before I went on Ellen I remember I just
moved to LA and I did the studio tour
and I was a big fan of Ellen from from
London and I remember going on the
studio tour and like you know being on
the lot and everything and thinking it
would be amazing to be on Ellen one day
and then later on that year I got
invited on so the first time I went on
uh Ellen came up to me uh in the green
room and said hello just to welcome me
to the show which was super sweet uh
then after that when I came on stage
when she gave me a hug so like you're
sitting like this on The Ellen Show she
gives you a hug when you walk on and she
whispered in my ear she said I'm so
thankful you're here like just really
like the almost time slowed down right
then we sat down we did an interview and
the whole time I thought she was gonna
band with me and make jokes right and
she was like really serious if you watch
our first interview I'm like I'm super
nervous right and I'm thinking like
she's gonna make fun of this and then
she doesn't she was just very present
and then at the end she she whispered in
my ear again she goes I hope I can have
you on all the time wow and I was just
like for someone to be that present and
personal and she's someone that I've
spent considerable a lot of time with
afterwards as well any personal
interaction I've had with her she's
she's really been present personal uh
extremely kind and uh this year my wife
and I got invited to go to Rwanda with
her oh wow to her gorilla Conservation
Center and so for three days we tracked
with gorillas mountain gorillas and just
what she's built there and and she's
amazing yeah and everyone who was there
traveling with her has been with her for
like 20 years so we were like the new
people on the group right uh like in the
sense that I've only known her for four
years and everyone else is like 20 years
in the team and she's surrounded by some
really wonderful people so again my
experience has been positive and I
appreciate what I'm sharing is my
experience of course yeah I'm only
speaking from my experience and uh um
but yeah she's she's been really warm to
me and I'm so grateful to her and she's
she's also always trying to help other
people like I've seen her like reach out
to other people in the queer community
and in other communities wanting to
support and even when someone's going
through the tough time if you'll have
friends she's loyal yeah so if you've
gone through a difficult moment or
anything like that she's she's right or
die for you and so that's rare too
because that is in this industry it's
like someone's going through a rough bag
everyone just like I don't want to be
around you you know and so I I would
honestly say that though those are some
of her best qualities okay I appreciate
your honesty now the final question I
have for you is because I'm so nosy
um you've had many celebrities on your
podcast whose has garnered the most
downloads ooh that's uh you've also had
Kobe Kobe Bryant on your podcast which
is
let's say like the the first two weeks
like you know immediately if like an
episode's gonna pop off like Candace
yeah Kendall is unbelievable it was wow
I think it was because she was so again
like you said like people don't really
know her or know much about her and so
it was behind the curtain yeah Kevin
Hart Kevin's yeah yeah Kevin's yeah
Kevin right now and and like in the
beginning I remember like you know uh
Kobe Bryant has been one of those
episodes of course I've seen clips of it
all over three months ago before he
passed away
um you know just super tragic yeah but
grateful I got to have that moment
within uh yeah the Will Smith episode in
in that year that it came out that was
the year before
that was huge and there were Evergreen
episodes right like yes so if anybody is
you know yeah they're on YouTube there
you can go back and it's not like it's
so timely it's about the person in
general talk about the day and also it's
the cumulative growth of the podcast
right like we're naming Kendall and
Kevin from this year because the show's
got bigger is when we started it was
yeah so but but it was it's it's been
interesting to me also what's really
beautiful is when the guest helps share
it as well and of course and opening you
up to a new community big thank you to
Kevin and Kendall who just you know were
sharing with their community and the
book is so good honestly it's called
Eight rules of love how to find it keep
it and let it go when it is the release
date 31st January January 31st you
pre-order it now get a copy of it it's
really good whatever phase of life that
you're in thank you so much for being
here it's such a pleasure to talk to you
it's so much fun we're gonna do this
again this is too much fun yeah thank
you guys so much for listening to the
toast we'll see you on the next one
deuces